[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the show a very
special Shanah Tovah to everyone who is
celebrating the new year today but even
that could not keep us away from the
show today and good thing because so
much happened over the weekend to start
with Donald Trump has cracked over the
weekend tweeting about the same
craziness about impeachment including a
ridiculous fox news segment nearly 20
times alone there close to a hundred
tweets in total I don't even know the
exact number and starting to suggest
that his own impeachment could lead to
an American Civil War we're gonna get to
all of the elements of this Donald Trump
tweeting endlessly a fox news segment
that reeks of desperation I am coining
the term adjectives a because the term
agitprop is not quite accurate it's a
little too Soviet in its connotations to
describe what it is that Fox News has
been displaying in defense of Donald
Trump against impeachment so I'm calling
what Fox is producing and Trump is
tweeting out better named adjutant ooh
urban dictionary Trump also threatening
civil war if he is impeached rouille
losing it so let's look at this
extraordinarily childish embarrassing
deluded behavior of what is ultimately a
panicked and terrified man that's what
we have today in Donald Trump look at
this non-stop barrage of failed attempts
at using the English language by Donald
Trump including nearly a dozen tweets
this morning three tweets this morning
about Adam Schiff that make no sense
enter just the normal types of attacks
we would see normally from internet
trolls but this is the President of the
United States earlier with another three
tweet storm about China quoting known
Trump sycophantic brown-noser Maria
Bartiromo who have spoken about before
and of course raising the term
witch-hunt that puts us up to six tweets
then he starts tweeting anyone who will
defend him he will just retweet them
anywhere that'll get you retweeted by
Donald Trump one interview with
Republican Kevin McCarthy who defended
Trump another of course would the
completely unhinged an outrageous
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham who
has become one of trumps a prominent
defenders another of Trump attorney Rudy
Giuliani Donald Donald Trump retweeting
that another TV segment from Lou Dobbs
on Fox Business were now up to ten
tweets and this is just the last nine
hours and this is all nothing compared
to what else happened on Twitter with
Trump then we go to late last night and
this is when Trump really was getting
himself wound up we're going sort of in
reverse chronological order in groups
here now with these I'm not going to
read every tweet because it's too insane
and it's just too much Trump attacking
Nancy Pelosi talking about impeachment
quoting Fox News and the radical left
and talking about Hillary Clinton and
going after the whistleblower these are
the endless unending tweets of an unwell
man and we are now up to 21 tweets about
this in the prior 12 hours 21 tweets and
then Trump goes on to the Fox News
adjutant and I encourage you to watch it
it's like close to 10 minutes long and
it featured this whacked-out right wing
or Mark Levin who's some I think it was
Sean Hannity who started calling him the
great one and it's like a completely
meaningless nickname and of course Mark
Levin defended Trump and said this is
all an unconstitutional attempt to
remove Donald Trump from power by a
means other than an election Trump
tweeted that segment endless times
hilariously sandwiched with a rosh
hashanah greeting in the
middle not counting that we are up to 24
tweets in the last slightly more than 12
hours related to Donald Trump's
impeachment and then I'm not going to
get into this in detail retweeting
endless just random people who went on
Twitter and said Mark Levin crushed it
on Fox News I'm not going to read each
one but these are just random Trump
sycophants who agree with a clueless Fox
News agitate and innocent Donald Trump
is about 30 tweets of that just random
people who Donald Trump is retweeting
more than a dozen others we're talking
about between the tweets and the
retweets and the adjectives
I think we're talking about a hundred or
so tweets here in total dating back to
the beginning of the weekend Trump just
retweeting anybody who's willing to
defend him on Fox News and a retweeting
Twitter randos who are saying good
things about him and then the cherry on
top the specific threat of a civil war
going back to one of Donald Trump's
tweets and retweets quoting pastor
Robert Jeffress or Jeffress he's a
radical extremist himself who we've
spoken about before saying quote if the
Democrats are successful in removing the
president from office which they will
never be it will cause a civil war like
fracture in this nation from which our
country will never heal that's Donald
Trump quoting pastor Robert Jeffress via
Fox News on Twitter this is not the
behavior of a well person this is not
the behavior of an innocent person this
is not the behavior of someone who has
no interest in interfering or tampering
with witnesses in what is now an
increasingly popular impeachment inquiry
against Donald Trump which I will talk
about next
the only real debate I mean listen when
I look at this nearly a hundred tweets
over the weekend President of the United
States
I don't debate wow does Donald Trump act
like an innocent or guilty person the
ship has sailed on that debate I don't
ask myself is Trump coherently using the
English language to communicate things
of meaning or is he not the guys come
incoherent that's not a debate in my
mind the only real question I have is is
the logical next place for Trump to be
removed from office and put in prison or
to be removed from office and put in a
mental institution and I don't mean that
satirically I don't mean it to be in any
way demeaning or stigmatizing or making
fun of actual mental illness and I know
a lot of people get mad and they say
David you know you're you're sort of
insulting mentally ill people when you
say Trump may be mentally ill he's just
a terrible person I don't know the
answer this is not a nun this is not a
well person that's what I can tell you
the other remaining questions are
increasingly being answered by these
erratic and nonstop tweets and the only
question I have is where is the logical
next resting ground for Donald Trump
support for Donald Trump's impeachment
has exploded drastically since the start
of the impeachment inquiry against
Donald Trump was announced last week
half of those who have an opinion about
this say that the impeachment process
should start it's 43 to 43 with about 13
percent undecided this 43% number is up
nearly 20% from the last poll which had
only 36 percent supporting impeachment
that is now up to 43 percent that is a
20 percent increase don't email me and
say I'm wrong I'm not saying it's a 20
percentage point increase it's a 20
percent increase very importantly
support for impeachment is up not just
among Democrats also among some
Republicans and even some independents
support for the impeachment inquiry has
increased and let's dig into it a little
more to get a better understanding
there's an argument the argument is
support for impeachment will go up as
more information from the impeachment
inquiry comes out and people realize
what it is Donald Trump is accused of
doing the poll has data that supports
that assertion shockingly in this poll
only 34 percent of Americans say that
they heard some about the Ukraine Fiasco
another 34 percent in this poll say they
haven't heard much or anything about the
Ukraine Fiasco so understand
with 68% of respondents saying they've
either heard nothing not much or only
some about the Ukraine fiasco
43% still support impeachment this
supports the idea that as people learn
about what has taken place support for
impeachment will go up even more this
poll by the way was taken before we
heard from Acting Director of National
Intelligence Joe McGuire in
congressional testimony this was a poll
taken before the release of the
recording in which Donald Trump implies
that the whistleblower or the informant
to the whistleblower should be killed
this 43% support level who was before
lots of the things that we've since
learned and then we have a newer CBS
News poll where 55% of Americans approve
with the impeachment inquiry an even
higher number meaning 55 - 36 is 19 19
divided by 36 that's more than a 50%
increase not percentage point more than
a 50% increase from when before all of
this from before all of this started now
that all being said this impeachment
inquiry could still backfire on
Democrats the reference point is look at
how Bill Clinton's impeachment backfired
on Republicans in the 1990s
that's a fair point of contrast although
there were some important differences
with the Bill Clinton situation Clinton
generally was more likable than Trump
but that's not my opinion that's the
polling Bill Clinton didn't interfere in
the impeachment process while Trump
already is and certainly will continue
to do so
Clinton's impeachment in the end he lied
but he lied related to an affair that he
had Trump has been caught red-handed
suppressing whistleblower reports about
his bribery and extortion of Ukraine for
the benefit of his twenty twenty
re-election campaign so there are
important differences between the
Clinton impeachment and the Trump
impeachment with Trump we are only at
step one which is the inquiry that's up
that's all that's where we are right now
but support up drastically since dressed
before this was announced let me know
what you think about all of this let me
know what you think about the inquiry
let me know what you think about support
for the inquiry I'm on Twitter at Deepak
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show I will be streaming tonight
probably on twitch at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman and I hope you'll join me
there as well the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com today's new members of the
day are kevin talk Haim and brad
matthews kevin and brad thank you for
your support this is a program that is
primarily funded by viewers and
listeners who say I like what you're
doing David I'm going to sign up and
contribute a few bucks a month or a
couple dozen dollars for the year which
you can do it join pakman.com takes
under a minute to sign up and I hope
someday you will not only be new member
of the day but longtime sustainer of the
day today Nancy Barnard is our longtime
sustainer of the day she's been a david
pakman show member for nearly 5 years
and I really appreciate your support
Nancy join these great people by signing
up at join pakman.com I believe that the
normal rates for membership are
extraordinarily extraordinarily
reasonable but if you would prefer a
discount you can use the code this is
20/20 and it'll save you 40% there's a
political consultant who went on MSNBC
and said if you were supporting Bernie
Sanders over Elizabeth Warren given
everything that we know today you are
sexist I wish that this was a fake
headline it is not let's look at the
video of Emily Tisch Susman saying this
in her own words doing the thing where
she says some people are saying if you
support Bernie over Warren it's sexist
and I think there might be something to
it take a look there's there's a ceiling
there is nowhere to go but there is no
up to go and all of those support I
actually heard overheard someone saying
that I thought was an interesting point
that basically at this point if you are
still supporting Sanders as opposed to
Warren it's kind of showing your sexism
because she has more detailed plans and
her plans have evolved I thought it was
an interesting point and I think there
may be something to it yeah I agree with
all that
what there are about there's at least
three layers through
we need to analyze this three lenses
through which we need to try to
understand this first of all it's just
the sheer stupidity of this comment if
you have two candidates and one is male
and another is female
if supporting the male is a sign of
sexism against the female candidate then
by extrapolation from that if you have a
Jewish candidate and a Christian
candidate and you support the Christian
candidate Elizabeth Warren in this case
that must be anti-semitism against the
Jewish candidate Bernie Sanders right no
I would be an idiot if I tried to make
that argument I would immediately lose
all credibility to put forth any kind of
political analysis which is why I'm not
going to make such a stupid argument and
that's equally dumb as what Emily's
hitch system and Sussman says here
that's the argument that's being made
and I hesitate to even use the term
argument because it's not really an
argument it's just nonsense so that's
problem number one the argument is
idiotic secondly we have here the
growing problem that I've been telling
you about last week I did a segment
where I said the critiques from left to
left the critiques among Democratic
primary voters of other Democratic
candidates are starting to get to be the
level of toxicity that is going to hurt
the eventual nominee and help Donald
Trump in 2020 okay these are the types
of more vicious and inaccurate attacks
that are going to self-destruct and lead
to the re-election of Donald Trump and
there are all sorts of reasons why
someone might support Bernie Sanders
over Elizabeth Warren and there are
reasons people are supporting Elizabeth
Warren over Bernie Sanders none of which
have to do with religion or gender
Bernie for example has been clear that
Medicare for all is the path forward for
health care now you can agree or
disagree with that that's his position
Elizabeth Warren has been more wishy
washy now you might agree with Warren
there are reasonable people who can say
you know I don't want to put all my eggs
in the medicare-for-all basket and so I
like Elizabeth Warren's more open-minded
approach or you could say I don't
see Elizabeth Warren is open-minded I
see her merely as wishy-washy and then
willing to take a position I'm going
with Bernie on this issue none of that
has to do with religion none of that has
to do with gender Warren voted for a
bigger Pentagon budget
Bernie voted against it that might be a
reason to vote for Bernie has nothing to
do with sexism obviously Bernie won't
take corporate PAC money in the general
and Elizabeth Warren will there's a big
argument to be had about that on the one
hand do you want someone who is
potentially going to be at a
disadvantage merely because they're
saying I won't take PAC money and my
opponent will and that hurts me or you
could say I love that Bernie is not
going to compromise principles and he is
not going to take corporate PAC money in
the general whatever right I'm just
telling you what the arguments are to
say that supporting the male candidate
because as Emily Sussman said Warren's
plans are more detailed supposedly is
absurd and pathetic it's it actually is
it's so sad that this is what things
have come to these are ridiculous
attacks that are baseless at their core
but they're destructive to the movement
there are serious critiques and
disagreements anyone can have with
Bernie or with Warren but this is absurd
childish and counterproductive now the
other thing layer three as we might call
it is that this particular consultant or
pundit or whatever Emily Tisch Sussman
she is part of the Democratic
establishment that has shown that they
don't like Bernie she's the former vice
president of campaigns for the Center
for American Progress an establishment
Democratic outfit her father Donald
Sussman was one of the top Hillary
donors in 2016 donating more than 22
million dollars to Hillary so I think
you probably understand what's going on
here this is truly terrible stuff you
hate to see it if what you care about is
removing Donald Trump in 2020 and
unfortunately more and more Democrats
are doing it I'm not saying everybody's
the same not every can that it has this
going on to the same degree but we've
seen enclaves of toxic Bernie supporters
we've seen toxic enclaves of Bernie
detractors we've seen Biden supporters
who were doing right wing talking points
about socialism and communism about
Bernie and Warren
we've seen ant Abidin people that are
going well beyond what the evidence
tells us should be the case and against
Biden into what our smears we've seen
Warren detractors we've seen the cult of
personality around Tulsi supporter on
Tulsi Gabbard with some of her
supporters yang supporters I've been
some of them have been going over the
line this is getting bad this is exactly
how we lose and I hope I mean what else
can I say I hope that everybody realizes
this and abandons this strategy now
speaking of which this may be one of the
last segments I do about Tulsi Gabbard
okay and it's an interesting one Tulsi
Gabbard gave a ridiculously laughable
interview to cultural critic and arbiter
of big ideas Dave Rubin
wherein she accepted Dave Reubens
ridiculous right-wing framing of
questions uncritically much the way that
many of the candidates did during the
early 2020 Democratic presidential
primary debates and Tulsi Gabbard has
now also started to attack Elizabeth
Warren in ways that are absolutely
ridiculous
she is also stepping back from Medicare
for also let's look in detail okay on
NPR's WBUR Tulsi Gabbard was asked about
Medicare for all and she was squirrely
once again saying quote yes I support it
I prefer to call it Medicare choice
where we are ensuring quality health
care for all people regardless of how
little they may have in their pocket or
their bank account while maintaining
their freedom of choice if they've got
an employer-sponsored plan or a union
sponsored plan that they're happy with
they should have the opportunity to do
so who's talking about taking away
whatever plans can survive in the market
if people want them at what they will
cost if a lot of people abandon those
markets this is the Republican framing
and those are the these are the right
wing questions at debates that need to
be called out as such she's asked do you
support Medicare for all she says well I
support choice because I don't want
people having the plans they have taken
away if they like them that that's the
right wing framing around this issue
that the issue is not making private
insurance illegal here's a clip similar
question that was asked
I also believe like every other
developed country in the world that has
universal health care that there is a
role for private insurance to play for
those who want it do you think for those
who are embracing taking away private
insurance from people ultimately is that
a just strategically politically a
non-starter I don't know about the
politics of it I just think about it
from the perspective of of people of the
American people that it all of a sudden
you are taking away their choice that's
not that's not a very American thing in
my opinion I think our responsibility as
leaders is to meet the challenge and
address the problems that people are
facing that they are suffering because
of big insurance and Big Pharma's
influence over our health care system
for so long how they are profiting on
the backs of sick people so let's do our
job try to bring down the cost of health
care in this country that's exorbitant
make sure people can get the quality
care they need and if they still choose
that that's not what they want they can
go get the private insurance I ask
focusing on you shouldn't take away
people's choice this is Republican
framing the debate over making private
insurance illegal is not the real
serious debate this is a silly talking
point that is being used by people who
want to avoid simply saying yes Medicare
for all is the way and you know what you
don't have to say that I would much
listen I don't agree with Joe Biden's
position on health care I just I just
think he's wrong I don't agree with it
but he's at least being upfront that he
doesn't see Medicare for all as the path
he's telling us he wants to play around
the fringes
he wants to tweak Obama care public
option he's talking about you he's
telling us what it is that he supports
this is the way that people talk about
Medicare for all when they want to avoid
saying yes I'm for Medicare for all
period or no I'm actually against it
they do this exact language about I
don't want to take away people's choices
now what's crazy is that there are Tulsi
sycophants who just won't stop accusing
anyone who points out what I'm pointing
out here of misrepresenting her or of
being a bad faith person this is the
exact thing that the jordan peterson
sycophants say anytime you
Jordan Peterson you are accused by his
followers of misrepresenting what he
said and that is exactly what is
happening with the many people who heard
what Tulsi said and realized that it's
not really making sense and then really
lame and also somewhat funny she
attacked Tulsi did Elizabeth Warren for
being unqualified to be President take a
look at this so you've been critical of
senator Harris in the past and even went
so far as to question whether she was
prepared to be commander-in-chief we now
see senator Warren really rising the
polls she's first in a lot of national
polls and several state polls as well
early state polls do you believe that
she's prepared to be commander in chief
I haven't seen much come from her in the
way of what kind of leadership and
decision-making that she would bring to
that most important responsibilities
that the president has as
commander-in-chief and and just as a
soldier and an American that that's very
concerning for me so you know for voters
I think that's an important thing to
look out for from everyone who's running
for president is what kind of experience
do you have in this area what kind of
depth and understanding do you bring to
these very nuanced and complex issues
with how the United States is relating
with other countries what kind of
leadership we're providing in the world
and having the kind of foresight and
judgment that we've seen leaders from
across both party lines have lacked for
far too long that have brought us to
this position where you know for for all
three of us we've seen our country at
war for the vast majority of the years
that we've been alive what is he talking
about and of course you know the
necessary both sides have lacked
leadership okay but in very different
ways that are not even remotely equal so
here's the deal first and foremost for
Tulsi to attack Elizabeth Warren and say
Elizabeth Warren is unqualified to be
President you could generally say we
need fewer lawyers and businesspeople
and career politicians in government
instead we need scientists and you know
what you could have that general
conversation and that's a very good
conversation to have but for Tulsi to
say
a Warren's not qualified to the extent
that being an elected official qualifies
you tell seize a member of the house and
warrens a member of the Senate view zero
that out then it's a debate is Warren's
experience with the CFPB her knowledge
of the law as a law professor her
experience teaching school tulsi was in
the military and was a local Hawaii
politician you can say neither's
qualified in the way that we want
presidents to be qualified but for Tulsi
to say Warren's not qualified is just a
joke when she's the one also running for
president right but here's the real
issue with Tulsi and with other
candidates let's step back a little bit
from Tulsi and make this a bigger thing
because tell us he's gonna be gone soon
she's got no shot at this thing the
cults of personality around some
candidates are problematic Tulsi Gabbard
has a huge cult of personality around
her I've been told although I've never
seen that there are entire YouTube
channels dedicated merely to doing Tulsi
apologia dependent defending anything
she says no matter how outrageous I've
been told there are similar channels
around Andrew yang can you imagine a
YouTube channel whose very existence is
just devoted to defending one candidate
like they are sort of heroic or almost
deifying them in some way and I remember
back in 2016 there were channels that
popped up like that around Bernie
Sanders and I voted for Bernie Sanders
in the 2016 Democratic primary but a
channel devoted to defending everything
that Bernie Sanders says and most of
those channels have of course evaporated
since 2016 although some are coming back
so the real problem I have with the
Tulsi sick offense and the Bernie or
Buster's the people who defend Trump
unfailingly unflinchingly is that
they've seemed to Ferg have forgotten
that people are just people one of the
things that hopefully we learn as we
grow up is that everybody is just a
person our parents aren't omnipotent or
omniscient right that that's something
you learn as you come of age our
teachers weren't and aren't all-knowing
they're just people and they know about
some stuff whether you're a Democrat or
a Republican the praying at the altar of
certain kin
it's like they are excuse the phrase
God's gift to humanity is extremely
concerning some politicians know more or
less about different things some are
more or less experienced but they're all
just people and I've met enough elected
officials to tell you they really are
just people they're flawed people people
who may do many good things and will
also mess things up and these
unflinching cults of personality from
the unconditional devotees are
disturbing and strange and they're not
the types of movements I want to have
any pardon and when people say David why
aren't you more strongly saying this is
the person that progressives need to
support in the Democratic primary I
don't see any of these people as a
perfect hypothetically in quotes rather
in the sense that a lot of the
sycophants do and I have no problem
saying you know there's a lot of people
here who are pretty good some are better
than others and there's no reason for me
to now come out and and maybe sort of
unwillingly even participate in the
growth of these cults of personality
I've told you Bernie and Warren are the
most progressive in my eyes they're both
flawed and we're and I'm going to
continue following it but these cults of
personality these movements that that
that are based around almost deifying a
candidate are very very concerning to me
and I want to hear from you what you
think about that we're actually going to
have a couple of posts about this on our
Instagram page at david pakman show
follow us there and follow me on
instagram at david pakman I may be
picking what could be the last green
pepper of the season from my pepper
plant later today
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show all right there's a new
report that the Trump White House has
been hiding not only the transcript with
the Ukrainian president's phone call
with Donald Trump but also transcripts
with Vladimir Putin as well as Saudi
royals including the Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman and of course anyone
surprised why wouldn't they who would
believe that the White House has this
entire other computer system for hiding
things and the only thing they hid was
the transcript with the Ukrainian
president of course they're using it for
other things and there are new reports
which say that the transcripts from
calls with the Russian President
Vladimir Putin and a number of members
of the Saudi royal family again
including Mohammed bin Salman are hidden
on a separate server where does that
ring a bell
wasn't it Hillary who had problems with
private servers and improperly handling
information another instance of
projection from Donald Trump and of
course we already have the whistleblower
complaining alleging that this was done
with Donald Trump's Ukraine phone call
and now the New York Times and CNN have
been told by other sources that actually
this is being done with all sorts of
communications so this is number one
much worse than just one phone call and
then number two it's also much worse
than just Trump because we are now
getting more and more names of people
that are being pulled into the circle of
knowledge of who was aware that this was
going on there are allegations that
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo and then
national security adviser John Bolton
were the only people in the room for
some of these calls which were then
buried there are now committees that
want to question Mike Pompeo and John
Bolton Trump said he would have the most
transparent administration in history
the opposite is true going to new
lengths Nixonian lengths even
more than nick Sounion lengths to hide
transcripts the Trump administration has
ignored subpoenas of all sorts of
documents meant to increase transparency
they were asked for lease agreements
from Trump properties they were asked
for documents about the transfer of
nuclear technology to Saudi Arabia they
just ignore all of those requests when a
whistleblower comes forward to try to
expose some of this stuff
Trump is caught on a recording which I
played for you last week hinting that
either the whistleblower or the people
or person who informed the whistleblower
should be killed like we used to do to
people who committed treason this is not
transparent this is transparently
corrupt better said and they just don't
care and if you've been following the
administration you're not surprised at
the minutiae of it but what you really
have to understand you know we're we're
starting to think increasingly in post
Trump terms because either in a
year-and-a-half or in five and a half
years scary to think about Trump's going
to go and the long lasting impact will
be not only all of those judges that he
will have appointed by the time he's
done who will control the judiciary for
a very very long time not only the
alliances with other countries are
historic Democratic allies that Donald
Trump has ruined relationships with that
will be one of the legacies
but what Donald Trump has done is so
fundamentally at odds with democracy and
what you have to understand is that
there is actually in most democracies
even you know liberal democracies there
is a portion of the population that
wants tyranny or at least they're open
to tyranny rather than democracy as long
as they are the ones who get to enforce
it and that is maybe the most accurate
way to describe what we have in the
Trump administration we can point out
the individual authoritarian tendencies
we can point out Trump being just so
smitten with Duterte and Putin and Kim
jong-un and you know the whole list I've
also Naro whoever you want to include
and being increasingly distant
at odds with just Liberal Democratic
leaders Germany the UK
well not the UK anymore now that it's
Trump - Boris Johnson but you get the
idea
we can point that out but what underlies
this is that we really have a segment of
these right-wing authoritarians that are
about tyranny as long as it's a tyranny
they get to enforce and that is
extremely extremely scary and allegedly
and we'll talk about this next there are
some Republicans who if they voted on
impeachment on a secret ballot would be
willing to remove Donald Trump and
that's what I want to talk about next
former Republican Senator Jeff Flake
says that at least 35 Republican
senators would vote to remove Donald
Trump if the Senate impeachment vote
were private so let's back up a little
bit the entire time I've been talking to
you about impeachment
I've been accurately saying I believe
that as long as Republicans control the
Senate Trump will not be removed by
impeachment the House Democrats can do
their impeachment inquiry if it leads
them to saying we are filing articles of
impeachment they can do it they can do
the impeachment trial but no matter what
once it goes to the
republican-controlled Senate which there
will be at least until January of 2021
and I believe until January of 2023
based on the the Senate election map you
are not going to remove Trump because
Republicans would not vote to convict
Trump on an impeachment charge now I've
not mentioned it but implied in this is
that impeachment votes in the Senate are
public the way you see senators vote on
stuff yay nay up a vote down vote the
way they do that they would publicly
vote on impeachment in that same way but
in the back of my mind
and that of many others was the question
of imagine that the Senate impeachment
vote was not public but instead it was
private so at the end of the vote you
would get the number of senators who
voted to impeach and the number of
senators who voted to acquit would you
have some Republicans who would be
willing to vote for the removal of
Donald Trump if that's where the
evidence brought them would Republican
senators vote to impeach Trump if they
knew the
their vote would not be public and
therefore they would potentially not be
subject to the political repercussions
of it and the growing idea according to
a couple of reports is that the answer
is yes we first heard from Republican
political consultant Mike Mike Murphy
and Mike Murphy said on MSNBC that if
the vote was private thirty Republican
senators would back impeachment then we
heard from former Republican Senator
Jeff Flake who said it the Texas Tribune
festival over the weekend that it's not
or Thursday it was it's not thirty
Republican senators that would vote to
impeach Trump it's more like at least
thirty-five who would back impeachment
if the impeachment vote were private and
because of the balance of power you
actually don't even need 30 or even 35
Republicans to get behind impeachment
you would only need about twenty
assuming that all Democrats and
independent senators voted for it but
this is mostly hypothetical because once
again it's not a private ballot it's a
public valve ballot just like everything
that goes on in the Senate there's one
other element to this which is it's not
as simple to say if the vote were
private 35 Republicans would be in favor
of it because even if the vote were
private those Republican senators who
vote against impeachment would come out
and say afterwards even if it's a
private vote I voted against impeachment
and this would immediately put the
spotlight on the Republicans that don't
come forward and say I voted against
convicting and they would either have to
lie or admit it so it's sort of a
fantasy that it would even go down in
this way but what this signals then is a
huge cowardice on the part of the
Republicans because if it's true that
they're only willing to vote to impeach
if the vote is secret and it doesn't
have political ramifications for them
it's merely a political calculation now
the upside if we want to find a silver
lining here is that I guess they're not
all blindly loyal to Donald Trump
the downside is they're afraid to act on
it unless it's done in a way that it
will have no consequences whatsoever
I read a comment online when researching
the story that sums it up as they're not
all traitors some merely have no
integrity
it's not even just lack of integrity
there's also the issue of hypocrisy
because in addition to the Lackey
lacking integrity they would instantly
be voting to impeach a Democratic
president who had done all of the things
that Donald Trump has done this may not
even be a decision they end up having to
make were just at the beginning of the
inquiry which happens before articles
are filed which would happen before all
of the other things that we've discussed
but if Jeff Flake is only 20% correct if
Mike Murphy is only 30% correct that
means that there would be the desire
from enough Republicans in the Senate to
impeach that it could remove Donald
Trump but mark my words you are not
going to see it under this current
republican-controlled Senate
let's take a break we will be back with
much more right after this
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
there are numerous hilarious new reports
that box news has been dropped into a
state of complete chaos or more
accurately bedlam according to the
reports that are now out as a result of
the impeachment inquiry against
President Donald Trump remember I've
been telling you for a long time now
there is nothing fixed or immutable
about Trump and Fox News being on the
same team or on the same page Fox News
is right-wing media Fox News can be
Donald Trump's vehicle for promoting and
defending his lies and his propaganda
but also Fox News could separate from
Trump and say we are for conservatism
and conservative values which I find
despicable but certainly Donald Trump
doesn't represent Trump represents
yeah.the this cartoonish ignorant
Republican cluelessness not conservatism
that's for sure now you might remember
that this was the case for a while early
in the 2016 Republican primary before
Donald Trump gained momentum in 2015
even Fox News was not on Donald Trump's
side and very publicly they sparred but
eventually Fox News came around and
recently the commentary people on Fox
News people like Sean Hannity Laura
Ingraham Tucker Carlson that kooky judge
Jeanine Pirro they've remained stalwart
defenders of Donald Trump but some of
the news people have not Shep Smith
Chris Wallace John Roberts there are
others who have just been telling basic
uncontroversial truths about Trump and
on Fox News that goes against what
you're seeing from the opinion people
there are now endlessly entertaining
reports in New York Magazine and in The
Guardian and in other publications about
the state of total chaos in which Fox
News now finds itself since the news of
the impeachment inquiry against Donald
Trump went live to understand this you
have to understand that Fox News is one
entity but it's huge and it's a bunch of
smaller entities you've got the news and
opinion sides and on Fox News those two
sides are actually deliberately blurred
but they are still ostensibly separate
sides you have each show being its own
little island with its own production
team and writers and Friends that they
have in positions of power
Hannity for example having Trump
specifically as one of his powerful
friends and there are massive fractures
starting to develop at fox news since
the Ukraine Fiasco started so some
examples of this last week I played a
clip for you where Shepard Smith invited
Fox News a chief legal analyst senior
legal analyst Judge Andrew Napolitano on
his show and Napolitano said listen this
is not a political analysis this is how
these laws these statutes are defined
and if you apply Donald Trump's actions
to the statutes or maybe better said you
apply the statutes to Donald Trump's
actions Trump committed crimes and he is
impeachable period meanwhile you have
Tucker Carlson and Sean Hannity chalking
up the entire impeachment inquiry to a
witch-hunt Tucker
even invited this lunatic former
prosecutor Joe to Genova on his show who
straight-up said oh that other legal
analyst on Shep's show Andrew Napolitano
he's a fool and you've got Fox News
legal analysts eating themselves you
have Fox News hosts and anchors going
after each other and the next day
Shepard Smith went right back on air and
he said that Tucker Carlson is a
repugnant for not backing the legal
position of Andrew Napolitano when he
was attacked on air and this then led to
the Fox News CEO Suzanne Scott and the
president of the channel Jay Wallace
having to interfere to cool it down and
reportedly they told Shepard Smith
according to Vanity Fair that if he
attacks Tucker Carlson on air again he's
going to be pulled off the air
altogether that's not all you then saw
Juan Williams on a Fox News show called
the five and he said that his Trump
loyalist colleagues are merely repeating
White House talking points while Sean
Hannity was tweeting that everyone is
lying about what's going on at Fox News
and this is exactly as predicted at a
certain point you are not defending
so-called conservative principles by
defending Trump I am against these
so-called conservative principles but
Donald Trump doesn't actually represent
them in any serious way nothing that is
going on right now
about defending Trump's conservative
view on
abortion or taxation or foreign policy
is about conservatism this is just
arguing about how corrupt how criminal
how treasonous is this administration
and actual conservative thinkers to the
extent that they exist they're not
seeing anything that they can defend in
Donald Trump
other than I guess he's undoing some of
the things that Barack Obama did there's
a report that former Republican Speaker
of the House Paul Ryan is pushing Fox
News to abandon Donald Trump full stop
Paul Ryan might have the power to do
this because he's now on the board of
Fox News since leaving the House of
Representatives another one of these
revolving door swamp filling instances
but next year is going to be fascinating
to watch on fox news from a media
analysis point of view but we need to
capitalize on this by punishing trump by
making sure that trump is removed from
office because we don't want this entire
fox news thing to be some mere curiosity
or entertainment only we want it to be
productive in some way they are starting
to eat themselves Democrats need to make
sure not to do that as I warned earlier
in the show so that we can actually take
advantage of this situation and get
Donald Trump removed in November of 2020
one of the things that Donald Trump has
said a number of times now to try to
convince people that impeaching him is a
bad idea is he's been saying the stock
market would crash if I got impeached
now it's not a crazy thing to suggest
markets in general don't like
instability the removal of a president
or even the attempted removal of a
president is a form of instability so it
is reasonable to think wow if Trump were
impeached if Trump were impeached and
convicted for removal the markets would
absolutely crash and Donald Trump has
kept pushing this lately he tweeted late
last week quote if they actually did
this the markets would crash do you
think it was luck that got us to the
best stock market and economy in our
history it wasn't so put aside for a
second that most stocks are held by
relatively few people richer people and
so the level of the stock market is not
the best indicator of the health of the
economy
put that aside just for a second okay
there's a good case to be made that
markets would actually do really well
and might even soar rather than crash if
Donald Trump were impeached Rick Newman
from Yahoo Finance makes the case for
this and Rick points out that number one
markets have been relatively stable
since the impeachment inquiry was
announced you've actually seen very few
big swing days one way or the other
since the impeachment inquiry was
announced that's the first sign that we
should question this so-called
conventional wisdom of impeachment is
terrible for the markets but Rick Newman
actually says markets would soar if
Trump was impeached because the things
that Donald Trump has done which tend to
boost stocks now this is for better or
worse this is not me saying I agree with
these policies but Trump has done tax
cuts and deregulation very often that
boosts stocks of course there's a it's
it's there's an expense to that as well
which we can talk about those would in
principle stay if Donald Trump were
removed but a lot of the bad things
Trump has done would likely end the
tariffs the xenophobia interfering with
free markets even on things like
immigration immigration is great for the
economy the gains from immigration even
including undocumented immigration are
far greater than the costs to the
economy now this all has a cost to it
right low wages poor conditions for many
legal and illegal immigrants I'm not
making a moral analysis here I'm merely
making an economic one for the sake of
discussion and there is a strong case to
be made that if Donald Trump were
impeached and removed it would not crash
the stock market the way Donald Trump is
pointing out now there's a bigger
argument which is if the right thing to
do for legal reasons on the basis of the
evidence for moral reasons is to impeach
a president you do it you don't make the
calculation that in the short term the
market won't like it so we let a
president remain president who shouldn't
be president that's a separate argument
what we're talking about merely is the
practicality and the logistics of the
market will crash versus the market will
soar if Trump is impeached let me give
you another example the craziness with
Iran what's bad for markets is the
instability with Iran which would
probably calm down
if Donald Trump was removed from office
now Rick Newman is also saying that if
Trump were replaced with pence the
economy would be much better off
I find pence disgusting and it would be
terrible but the main point here that
Rick Newman is making and which i think
is a valid point to make or at least to
propose is that Donald Trump's removal
would not be terrible for the economy as
a foregone conclusion and we need to
challenge all of those ideas merely
because they might have been accurate 20
years ago merely because it seems to
make some intuitive sense does not mean
that we should fall for it hook line and
sinker and more importantly one way or
the other this is not the basis on which
impeachment should be decided upon we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p this is pretty
funny last week we had a voicemail that
I didn't really understand which said
hey David is the entire Bernie Sanders
thing a distraction and I wondered which
thing and a distraction from what we
have now someone following up who is
concerned about another distraction on
the program take a listen to this hi
David this is Michael from Missouri I
wanted to just call and ask you about
the whole producer pad thing I mean do
you think that it's a distraction
thanks yeah you know I do think that the
entire producer Pat thing is a huge
distraction and that's why we're going
to be asking him about it on today's
bonus show where we will discuss there
is a growing movement that says TV
producers are doing something ethically
wrong by putting Rudy Guiliani on TV
because he just lies that's all he does
Joe Biden is one of those people we will
talk about that we will also talk about
the investigation into Hillary Clinton's
emails now you're probably thinking I'm
kidding I'm not kidding the Trump
administration is now in the wake of the
impeachment inquiry in the wake of being
caught red-handed
not even saying that they were trying to
collude as an understatement
forcing collusion with Ukraine they are
now ramping up an investigation into
Hillary Clinton's emails it is still
going on we will also talk about a very
interesting interview
with former British Prime Minister David
Cameron who is calling the brexit
referendum that led to everything we
have seen since January 23 2016 the day
of that vote his greatest regret and it
still is not clear in fact it is sort of
more and more clear it's it's unclear
that brexit is going to happen you could
also argue it is more clear that it is
not going to happen but we'll have that
conversation on the bonus show all of
those stories and more including the
distraction of producer Pat as the
voicemail caller said on today's bonus
show two ways to get access become a
member at join pakman.com become a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show and remember you can call the
voicemail number 24 hours a day and many
of you do the number of voicemails we
get between like 2:00 and 5:00 a.m.
Eastern Time is is high it's very very
high two one nine two david p is the
number and i hope you will join me this
evening for a live stream on twitch at
twitch.tv slash david pakman follow me
subscribe there with twitch prime and i
hope you'll join me this evening
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]